where's the Chinese Steve charities was
fire team ha ha
you are lies there it is I'm doing it
worse
fire team have the gaming high and
gaming oh this is great it's doing it
it's live
okay well I'm live on YouTube everybody
welcome to yeah Eric Griffin comedy oh I
should yeah go yeah I'm gonna tweet this
out huh I don't even know how to do that
oh I'm in the childís people chatting
with me right now
oh yeah what's up guys hey hey what's up
riffing with Griffin fans I'm also a
avid gamer so here I am game in get in
my game didn't Matt game do I need a
gaming theme song I need a gaming theme
song give me your what you can hide
stuff alright here we go
oh you just go to Eric Griffin comedy
yeah Eric Griffin comedy oh you do
[Music]
playing destiny play and that's the knee
[Music]
okay then I know what that is
I know I don't think there is God down
there might because you're watching two
stream oh [ __ ] Oh
what other seams are they watching yeah
oh twitch oh that's you guys okay
alright good good oh you just trippin
live now oh that's dope
I like how that looks okay so this is
destiny everybody that watches destiny
destiny just me are we gonna play gambit
let's do this so I'm playing gambit with
my worst fireteam guys that's Pikachu
and then this is uh our resident UFC
fighter Erich Koch who was gonna fight
but he got injured but look for him to
fight again to fight again yeah Hales
yeah somebody said somebody said
somebody said tell Fatih to stay off the
chips I mean you do sound like a fat
[ __ ] you know to me like what are you
doing dude start eating chips okay can
we start are we gonna do get I'm gonna
go to orbit all right
oh you did oh I wasn't paying attention
sorry alright um let me go to this oh
there it is joining fire team so anyway
so this is the destiny this is the game
destiny that I talked about with Steve
and Bobby all the time this is a game we
play bro 94 people are watching like
what am I not been doing this is insane
you know saying
yes um I said you're looking forward to
your next fight flash nipples for a $30
paypal let me see the money first month
money before nipples son money before
nipples No
so you just now you know this just a
teaser y'all this little worth fireteam
teaser I'm not trying to like break the
bank already where people just give me
money we're not gonna do that
oh now everybody's alright I make sure
you make the chat private cuz people can
see their our names so they're like you
know I'm gonna try to join but anyways
this is destiny
and we're about to play this game gambit
Gambas fun I've been playing destiny
somebody's talking about he tried to get
me to play destiny [ __ ] I've been
playing destiny for five years I'm day
one destiny I know people that way they
trying to get me to something new just I
hope you enjoyed my last episode of
rhythm with Griffin that was what he
call it uh RJ Cuyler you know Power
Ranger and he's from
I'm dying appear and white boy Rick
fantastic young kid vault of glass
remember vault of glass god I used to
have my pants no we're not getting uh
yeah our G's got great chemistry riff
they we clear he fade off so please
you games yeah yeah this guy yeah this
guy that we play with he's been working
where do you work again now you work at
where do you work in San Francisco yeah
but where do you work
he works at tender greens and somebody
at tender greens somebody at tender
greens no that's right
multiple people at the tender greens
touch his nuts regularly okay they grab
his balls regularly they regularly grab
his balls and he's so nonchalant about
it you know why yeah how long has it
been going on they've been grabbing your
nuts at this job a year they've been
grabbing his nuts for a year a year
everybody doesn't make it ten if
somebody said tender sack welcome to
tender sack oh man dude that doesn't
make any sense you should just quit
already why why people people are
inviting me to like darydary their part
I'm in the middle of something like it's
not gonna
yeah this is not gonna happen y'all wait
you know what let me get this on Twitter
real fast to you tweet this out let me
tweet this out there baby
yeah why does this take so long to
[ __ ] load man Jesus
oh no my gaming hey wait
okay all right um yeah so this is a
boring loading screen
finally [ __ ] students I'm in my bed
I know Gare [ __ ] all right all right
my daddy's comfortable gaming with
Griffin cabal on the field
oh [ __ ] do I have the right weapons wait
wait okay I could do with deep oh no I
don't want that gun
I need a [ __ ] oh man I'm gonna lose
all my ammo no I lost all my ammo yeah
this is gambit oh you know it's a good
gun for this map is the that's a risk
runner because you can just activate it
in that that [ __ ] right there
get this cabal mmm oh my god oh it's
already starting it's already starting
here we go everybody already like
nonsense is already ensuing Oh God I
don't know almost leaving my fault
yeah so you have to like ah ah Oh howdy
bullets
dude when you like don't have your gun
in the beginning if when you switch it's
just not good oh we got two warlocks oh
man some I took my that was mine
yeah I want to play some little all
right you know what I'm just gonna put
I'm putting this little blocker in I'm
gonna put this alright
oh [ __ ] I'm about to die okay there we
go
sicut small blocker
oh man
okay there we go wait one more I can't
put another small blocker in did you
invade who invaded oh gods seven motes
get your [ __ ] together
yeah but five is less than 7 just FYI
invaders gone
yes okay I'm going in with another
little blocker don't whine in with a
little water oh my god yeah
I have love malfeasance oh good Oh cuz
he almost got me
wait let me grab these okay there we go
yeah let him do it we got to get these
mopes anyway
incoming weights actor drill man I'm not
getting any all right here we go
take the reloading of the weapons is
second how do they already have a
primeval oh my god
so annoying oh my god okay Rafi
okay all right wait they I have my super
all right we will need six like stop why
is everybody messing around just put
them in we don't need everybody over
there for four six motes there we go
burn that primeval to the ground
where's the primeval I came to see this
[ __ ]
oh my god he's wrecked me yeah I'm
playing with my hands how can i yep I'm
a youtuber now y'all on my youtuber I'm
a gamer youtuber what is happening get
this Oh My gods
where did it get me from well this is a
this is a we're gonna we're not gonna
win
we got we got we got it when you get
this let me get this heavy man we almost
did it well I have 30 38 percent
primeval well that's gambit y'all your
team's horrible everybody else pick it
up come on man
[ __ ] is like come on I'll get tougher
dude this is crazy this is the most
people ever watching us game yeah
okay we got this yeah there we go there
we go
that pistol action see in this game you
got it we gotta collect motes collect
these little triangle things that drop
and we have to put them in this thing we
got to get 75 then before the other team
and then once you put them in you get to
send these like these things so they
send them to your side and you send them
to New York to the blockers yeah so and
it's like the first team to 75 this
oh yeah baby what my super still going
take it over on route to the attorney I
just made a bunch of moats right there
do you guys watch your one freaking orb
right there
oh no yeah this is the game that kalila
won't let Bobby play everybody whoever
is watching those people are staying in
a chat yeah they're looking they're like
what the hell's going on you know it's
not my fault
[Music]
I just stopped 30 motes good you just
keep doing that we'll handle this go
look them in the eyes
dude the sins of the past is still the
best rocket launcher you know all the
it's just like just the damage you know
and if you haven't master worked already
go ahead go in hand oh we already have a
primeval hell yeah son
[Laughter]
oh yeah we got kilt
oh [ __ ] I'm getting the other blizzard
right here there we go there we go
melt in time where is the guy where do
you guys see him the I think he's coming
from coming from sticks no one the base
that area I'm trying to go get him
oh I see him I see him I see him how
he's got he's going yeah we got it
they're never gonna become there's no
way they can catch up we'd have to just
be like complete nincompoop let them
catch up at this point but it's happened
before
I know we've been known to [ __ ] [ __ ] up
why is the sky okay
where's he coming from anybody see him
already
oh my god god damn it it's okay I lost
to the main guy okay okay I'm coming in
with I'm coming with a super and I'm
making some orbs for the for the next
time oh we got this bye bye
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's how you do it son that's how you
play destiny thirty motes deposited
twenty-four no I don't like overwatch
243 now do you know wait let me go - let
me go to Twitter and like it and when
you call it retweet my own tweet no not
just until a knight black ops where is
it well there we go there we go retweet
okay now here we go let's do this oh
[ __ ] my laptop is about to die oh my god
[Laughter]
[Applause]
here we go
laptop power up oh my god okay I'm
coming people oh yeah of course mate is
back okay all right wait there we go
okay
okay I'm like really I really messed up
okay I'm gonna get these middle guys you
guys just keep getting most okay I
cleared the middle whoo
okay there you go y'all that's how you
get your game on oh okay now we're back
down this 205 all right all right where
are we Oh at the base hi there you
target neutralized oh man they have 48
dude oh no I didn't lose any mode stuff
didn't lose any moves
Griffin with rich and his gang oh [ __ ]
he just [ __ ] me up I was in mid jump
and this guy blew my head off
I'll come a clear the middle
so I got a malfeasance okay done middles
clear what the hell why are they
shooting at me
give me up thank you oh man that's
[ __ ] took the [ __ ] Rockets I
got some markets no come on we should
get enough right here all right you're
gonna have to go across coke while we
handle this [ __ ] okay here we go let's
look at all these modes that's gotta be
enough 52 that's got to be enough all
right let's do it let's do it I have to
have three f3 let's put them all in we
got a win for the street let's get this
money all right I'm gonna get these
wizards yo son I'm using all my super on
this one he's got he's got he's gone I'm
getting rid of these other [ __ ] okay
I got a little arc sole over here okay
where's the invader anybody see him
where's he at
I think he's up here really
oh man it's over oh man I'm gonna take
that loss that was my the laptop charger
snafu
it was charger gate that was charger
gate everybody good morning everybody
thanks for watching what's my [ __ ] yeah
yeah well my 14 didn't hope I'm good
morning everybody that's in the chat
we're playing a little candidate right
now I play a little too cable I might
play a little 2k you know this let's
make this a destiny I play 2k to another
color maybe tomorrow riffing with
riffing gaming nice god damn what's up
with that
why is your guys thing taking so long
wait doesn't your xbox is run in the
background like like don't they don't
don't you have them on on your internet
just rip Wayne even when it's off cuz my
[ __ ] is going in the background that's
why when I turn it on it's already gone
yeah you should auto update everything
you got a auto-update all right who's
out there who's playing games out there
what y'all playing let me know what you
guys are playing you know and by the way
I don't even see that well first of all
my full name is Eric Graham Griffin so
I'm gonna start calling my fans
eggheads okay yeah you got coke heads
and eggheads oh that's perfect we should
yeah oh we should make a t-shirt coke
cans and egg heads that's perfect yeah I
need some uh nice theme songs and an
artwork for riffle or Griffin don't be
bashful
send them in he's still doing it we out
here doing it y'all refresh
I'm getting bad connections come on my
man I'll be getting back to the shop
I wish made assertive scream is good I'm
like I couldn't get on to it on my own
oh damn it I think I am this is terrible
yeah I can't even oh man I can't even do
anything right now
alright alright alright I gotta get out
of this
so working
oh man I'm yeah my laptop is like
straining to do this right now
[Laughter]
no it's just I can't even load like my
chrome anymore to like look at the chat
or anything yeah I'm not even in the
right place but this dough is still
looking good live right
yeah yeah yeah I know I know I know
oh man yeah it is no I'm not God shut up
Craig what I gotta close other [ __ ] I
gotta close other [ __ ] yeah yeah I got
I'm getting my horrible framerate I just
got to close apps
I gotta closes that sold on y'all sorry
close that close this okay that's what I
think my email app was open and the
email app was [ __ ] [ __ ] up this okay
there we go there we go okay keep plenty
of hold on y'all come on
yeah I'm still dropping frames well this
is a work in progress people going why
is it now doubt a Game Capture receiving
fewer repeater rates that expected click
read about okay yeah I don't know what
to do I mean
yeah I'll just stop I mean this is like
this is like you know some late night
game and I'm gonna do every now and then
guys a little little extra room with
Griffin Griffin with worst fire team
that's what I'll call it I'll [ __ ] the
bigger where is it oh you got me
freaking got me man sucks yeah I'm gonna
finish this hey guys I got this uh
ghetto internet right now but I'm
working on it that's why I need some
more before from with Griffin support so
I can upgrade the Internet
ah [ __ ]
we're still doing good though
damn I hate these thrall man Oh what
that didn't kill this guy I just hit him
with a full-on rocket to the face
nobody should survive a rocket to the
face y'all 1fps what does that mean no
it doesn't it's not overheating or
anything it's just stupid oh well y'all
yeah we're always looking for some nerd
help
okay here we go
come on come on come on oh man I just
got I just got rekt portal suck
on Wi-Fi so yeah there's just nothing to
be done about it y'all oh it stopped
it's back to normal
I'm keep going come on man there's still
a wizard up come on this full health -
oh good - got it we got it
invaders coming from the right oh my god
what killed me what it was killed by the
architects that is so annoying one
minute left
oh I have to sign in oh this is annoying
yes look at me with bad internet with
bad internet come astray I love how it
says live now within live gaming I'm
back I'm surprised mr. instigator today
is not today piece of [ __ ]
oh my god
six months somebody said I was weird
sexy what a backhanded compliment you
know yeah son what's up Robert
I'm just saying hello to [ __ ] at ya
yeah I don't know what's weirder you
calling me weird sexy or being weird
sexy what's weirder well that was the
worst grenade in history
yeah yeah yeah get it get it get it get
it get it ah son I mean it's just that's
gonna be getting an average of like 200
people watching gaming I might have to
just not be my new thing
well I wanted to wait till I like build
up a little bit you know that's really
what oh my god this invader just they
just show up out of nowhere dude it's so
[ __ ] frustrating
somebody said bring back the fire squad
this is the fire squad hello ray
neon is worse fire team without Bobby
and Steve well yeah we're at 33 oh [ __ ]
we're only at 33 I'm gonna get these
guys in the center here oh [ __ ] and we
got an invader oh my god how they got a
primeval this ain't gonna work
okay
there we go we got 39 where's the I'm
gonna use my super on the next where's
it at
okay I want to use my super over here oh
actually just another oh wow
do you do more motes drop when you do a
when you uh what do you call it get a
precision kill the more motes drop do
you know that oh it's just amazing that
sometimes sometimes enemies drop like
five or something you know and I can't
figure out why
wow that was a wrecking I hated your
heavy doesn't weigh over well I had nine
six months to deposited nine lost and
ten hostiles killed didn't do a good job
there wasn't very good on that one guys
[Music]
no [ __ ] is dropping frames again
incoming wave at their ruins it's gonna
be next month we're gonna do it once a
month we're gonna do it once a month
y'all once a month Bobby and Steve are
gonna come on I would be talking horror
movies next time there was some good
ones this past year yeah I did I watched
it I really enjoyed it actually
yeah I like those kind of like weird
Andy but it was very um Rosemary's Baby
you know
yeah but why go to twitch if I can do
this none I mean all right guys I quit I
put a little blurb and some of my video
info of a lot of my videos yeah I just
don't think people look at that [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] I got 15 an attorney and I'm over
here [ __ ] around this is usually when
the that's usually when the when the guy
comes
we're actually streaming on twitch and
YouTube at the same time guys if you
want to see what Pikachu looks like yeah
if you want to see that uh oh my god
I just lost six most like an [ __ ] I
gotta figure I was going on my internet
it's just really annoying losing a Vader
right there okay we're still gonna get
it though come on let's get this
get this guy oh [ __ ] that's that dust
John wick style right yeah I just blowed
his head off
[Laughter]
now what i'm gonna use my super over
here
no kill this guy oh [ __ ] I just look 15
god damn it dude that's so annoying
oh my god I had it Jesus Christ dude
that was a great invade that was just
prime invasion right there guys oh man
I'll just do it what's gonna put it I
don't care how many I have I was so
infuriating
keep that wrong no I just keep doing it
we're almost there
[Music]
there we go primeval
come get this Ark soul it's right behind
you oh my god where is it I mean some oh
man
I just killed the whole [ __ ] what I
mean
why nice a guy just shooting me I know
but it's not healing him you got to go
again oh man okay well that's it good
orbit our guys thank you for watching
and let me go into the chat with us yeah
wasn't it great it wasn't great well we
tried to do it but this is me late night
gaming every now and then you know I did
it thanks for paying attention thanks
for watching I wish man yeah guys you
don't gotta be [ __ ] about it though
you know they're mean all right let me
just give into this chat real fast let's
say goodbye all right well we got 163
people watching at a certain time that
was good stuff all right guys I'll see
you later
thanks for watching